South Korea is restarting its
professional sports leagues as the
corona virus infection rate slows down
the government is allowing outdoor sport
starting with a hugely popular baseball
league but fans cannot attend the games
Rob mcbride has more from this idiom in
India this is the last practice session
before the long-awaited start of their
day one of South Korea's baseball season
a season that of course has been delayed
by more than a month because of the
corona virus we're here at this stadium
in Incheon that's the home of the SK
wyverns that's in jion's local team who
are taking on visitors Hanwha Eagles
they are down on the diamond at the
moment having now prep their practice
session now it is a longer way to start
this has been well over a month that
we've waited for this baseball season to
get under way and very strict
precautions are in place to make sure
that all the players are safe a certain
amount of social distancing is practiced
they are not allowed to do high-fives
and shake hands also notably for
baseball players they're not allowed to
lick their fingers that's a tricky for
the pictures and also nobody is allowed
to spit most notably of all no
spectators are being allowed in in place
of spectators what we have on some parts
of the stands are simply painted cutouts
of spectators all of them obediently and
very correctly wearing masks but no
spectators themselves are allowed in
instead people are allowed to see this
now that's the important part of this
game on the start of the Korean season
they are supplying a worldwide demand at
the moment for live sports South Korea
is one of the top three baseball playing
nations in the world of course the
United States and Japan are ahead of
them but in South Korea they are the
first to get their baseball season
underway so all of the matches that are
being played by the ten major teams in
the Korean baseball organization are
being streamed through at the likes of
ESPN to a worldwide audience so that
they can get their fix of
live baseball when the spectators can
come back that is still an open question
here they are hoping possibly within the
next one to two weeks to start
introducing spectators back into the
stands here but even when they do it'll
be a long time before we have packed
stands here they will only be in reduced
numbers with empty seats between them